the steering wheel the tire the seat the
rearview mirror utterly standard parts
of your car except in the mirrors case
it wasn't the cars were in use for over
30 years before the rearview mirror
became common
I guess people just swerve to hope for
the best in fact the first use of the
rearview mirror wasn't even for safety
it was just a way for a driver to go
extra fast
[Music]
back in the day race cars at a team of
two the driver and a mechanic the driver
drove obviously and the mechanic fixed
stuff but here's the critical thing the
mechanic had one other duty they
directed the driver when the car was
clear to pass or change lanes
rayher hoon was a driver in the 1911
Indianapolis 500 and he was looking for
an edge gray figured that if he ditched
the mechanic the car would be a lot
lighter and therefore faster
so he borrowed an idea he saw on a horse
and buggy a mirror to change lanes
he won the race but the mirror turned
out to be so shaky it didn't really
catch on it took ten years for someone
else to try experimenting with a mirror
a guy named Elmer Berger Elmer was an
engineer who also liked to go really
fast but he wasn't a race car driver he
just liked to speed so he created the
mirror and he called it the cop spotter
so you see it's not just for dad's
checking on their kids fighting in the
backseat it's really about speeding so
the next time that you're navigating
through a sea of cars on some domestic
errand going really fast and you see
flashing red-and-blue lights appear in
that mirror you're using it as the
founders intended
[Music]
you
[Music]